failed former president Donald Trump who
again wants to be president starting in
January of 2025 is reportedly planning
to bring back firing squads for the
execution of death penalty sentences and
wants to televise elements of those
executions maybe not the most gruesome
part but at least elements of it this is
all part of Trump's I guess New Look
2024 campaign in which he's talking
about executing drug dealers who he
falsely claims are responsible for 500
deaths each a line he is often repeated
at rallies there is a wild wild Rolling
Stone article by asawin subsang and
Patrick rice Trump plans to bring back
firing squads group executions if he
retakes the White House and the article
explains how Donald Trump has been
asking more and more Associates about
this idea Trump is committed to
expanding the use of the death penalty
the article writes and he wants to bring
back some banned methods of execution he
is even One Source says mused about
televising footage of executions
including showing condemned prisoners in
the final moments of their lives this is
very deranged it is extraordinarily
authoritarian and we should all be
genuinely scared about it the article
continues Trump has talked about
bringing back death by firing squad by
hanging and according to two of the
sources possibly even by guillotine he
has also discussed group executions and
he floated these ideas while discussing
planned campaign rhetoric and policy
desires as well as his disdain for
Biden's approach to crime here's another
wild element to this in at least one
instance late last year Trump privately
mused about possibly creating a flashy
government-backed video ad Campaign
which would accompany a federal Revival
of these execution methods in the vision
that Trump has the videos would have
footage from the new executions if not
from the exact moments of death the
source told Rolling Stone the former
president believes this would help put
the fear of God into violent criminals
he wanted to do some of these things
when he was in office but for whatever
reasons he didn't have the chance for
whatever reason Trump wasn't able to
bring back death by guillotine and then
televise the executions we don't know
why he just wasn't able to do it so this
is really really scary and crazy and we
are all right to see this and to cringe
and to say what the hell is this about
this guy is sick but there's another
more practical question I'm wondering
about is this going to get out the vote
is there a desire for from your average
Republican voter to have new and more
not new to revive the more brutal forms
of carrying out execution and death
sentences like the guillotine and firing
squads what about group executions I
mean you know the the the sort of funny
there's very little that's funny about
this very very little it's genuinely
horrifying the one part that is funny is
that there's a little detail in there
that shows Trump's lack of understanding
of how anything works when Trump talks
about group executions we all know it
takes so long to carry out a death
sentence between appeals and backlogs
and all of these different processes
that take place the idea that it would
even be logistically possible
to coordinate multiple Federal
executions on the same day and do it as
a group forget about the morality of it
forget about what it means for the
country forget about all the idea that
it would even be logistically possible
to carry that out just shows Trump's
complete and total lack of understanding
of how anything works and a complete
lack of a connection to reality but he
wants to do it my question is is there
really an appetite for this even from
Republican voters who were willing to
vote Trump do they want this I have a
hard time believing that they do one of
our sponsors is zipx nicotine toothpicks
don't you think it's time you stopped
putting smoke and vape oils in your
lungs zippix toothpicks are a convenient
way to curb the nicotine Cravings zipx
toothpicks are super discreet you can
use them anytime anywhere smoking and
vaping aren't allowed including flights
sporting events in restaurants they're
available in six different flavors with
options of two 2 and 3 milligrams of
nicotine if you're not a nicotine user
zipix also offers caffeine and b12
infused toothpicks zipx has already
helped tens of thousands of customers
ditch the cigarettes ditch the Vapes
they might be able to help you too if
you're a smoker or a vapor give zipx
toothpicks a try your lungs will thank
you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below